hello YouTube Chancellor see my friends
this is vision here nowadays I'm
exploring a lots of new openings and
recently I came to know about a jack
park system now when I was learning this
opening I was looking for the games in
the database and I found one game where
GM Julian Hudson beat Johnny Ames in
just 24 moves and when I have gone
through the games I learn a trap exists
in this system so today we are going to
discuss about that trap now many of you
does not aware about what is a checkbox
system well the move is like this so
white plays d4 black responds with
normal pub defense Morris where black
plays d6 and after d4 Knight f6 and
Knight c3 the normal mu orders for the
pub defense is g6 but the Jack Park
systems start with a move c6 now this is
a very versatile opening where black is
waiting how wide is replying so for
example black can either go for the
filardo position where it can leads to
the e5 move it can go back to the normal
park defense models where it can play
g6n in some variation black can either
go with a 6 and e-file going back to the
caro-kann defense now against the park
of the modern defense the most
aggressive reply from the white is a
pseudo Australian attack which start
with the move f4
that was happens in this game so one of
my opponent plays f4 and the most
reliable reply here is as per the theory
of the jackpot is queenie file now the
first point is it's spinning the night
so now black is threatening to capture
the epon now here why it has a for good
reply now if the pawn goes further then
it will be a transposition to over line
the other two replies are Bishop to d2
and Bishop to d3 well against each of
them I'm recommending you play e5 and
learn the theory of the jackpot which we
are not discussing today the most organs
should apply from the wide which my
opponent play which is this one so Queen
f3 and not only it's protecting the pole
but now the white is threatening to move
this pawn further so black has to
responds very very accurately and here I
played d5 so again renewing the track to
capture the pawn and the most obvious
response will be pushing the pawn
forward and my nice jump to the e4
square now the first good merits about
this night is and stopping any Bishop d2
movements and here the most logical
reply will be the ship to d3 attacking
the knight
and it's setting up a thread for the
black so if black foolishly think that
oh I can capture the rook this route in
the corner by capturing this night
but there there comes the big surprise
where white can play Bishop to d2 and I
think it's a lost position for black
look at the development of the white
pieces plus look at the space the white
gained so it's a disaster position for
the black so of course I didn't play
that because I have as I stated that I
have gone through this game so I said
his trap by setting up my own trap
by playing this move Knight to a six now
first sight it looks like it's a very
nursery looking move and not only that
black is offering upon to the white and
it's a very tricky line for example if
white greedily take the pole so for
example Bishop takes
be cross and queen cross then he has to
fail this move g6 and this is actually
happened in one of my game where my
opponent realize what kind of danger he
is in and he played Queen e2 I played
night before and after Knight f3 Bishop
f5 he realized that he cannot prevent me
to capture their c2 pawn and in the game
I won the exchange and the game so that
is one line where if the white become
greedy and kept the bond now of course
in one of my game my opponent was around
2300 plus and he decide to go with a
normal developing move so he played
night ge2 and his idea is to next move
he wants to castle and then we will
start attacking my king
but here I played Knight to be for
attacking his Bishop and now if I can
capture that Bishop white Bishop then
I'm doing very well here so my opponent
thought that probably I have missed
something and he captured the knight i
recaptured and then he captured by the
Queen and now he thought that here the
g6 is not possible and indeed it's true
for example if the black played g6 right
now then white can stop the Bishop f5 by
simple my g3 and now the Bishop f5 is
not possible now no matter how hard
black try for example if the black play
H file then I can simply play at 4 and
now Bishop fr is out of the case or it's
not possible
so probably my opponent thought that and
that's why he captured this but here
comes a very nasty trap I give you a few
seconds can you identify amazing move
over here
okay the movies
fi and and now you can see first thing
is this Queen cannot capture the point
because it has been protected by the
bishop this Queen cannot go to the d3
because the knight is attacking and if
the Queen goes away anywhere then the c2
will fall and not only that that that
leads to fall the rook in the corner so
the only reply left is to take the pawn
by unperson but now comes a complete cue
trap which is Bishop to f5 and now you
can see my queen is protecting the
bishop and not only that these two
pieces are eyeing the juicy C 2 square
and it's a very amazing trap exist in
this jackpot and I give you guarantee up
till now probably three to four people
have fall into this trap and
yeah please remember this trap I hope
you enjoy my video please feel free to
comment and I'll post a new video soon
bye